known territory or what's explored
unknown territory or what's not explored
the trans transformation or the
dissolution of one into the other and
then the reconstitution of that that's
what an election does right it's like
okay we have our leader who's the person
at the top of the dominance hierarchy
and defines the nature of this
particular structure there's an election
it's regulated chaos no one knows what's
going to happen it's the death of the
old king bang we go into a chaotic state
everyone argues for a while and then out
of that argument they produce a
consensus and poof we're in a new state
right that's the meta story right order
chaos order but it's partial order chaos
reconstituted and revivified order
that's the thing is that this order is
better than that order so there's
progress and that's partly why I think
the idea of moral relativism is wrong
there's progress in moral order and and
it was defined properly by Piaget the
new moral order does everything the
other baurel the old moral order did and
some additional things that's what
constitutes progress now here's a here's
a strange idea and we'll talk about this
more as we progress through the class
what's the ultimate in order well it's
not this obviously because it can
collapse and it's not this because it
can collapse and so then you think well
there's no ultimate order even though
there's progression but then you have to
move it up one level of abstraction
what's the ultimate order doing this
willingness to do that that's the
ultimate order right it's order at a
different level of analysis and you can
see that's what's represented in that
idea that's what that idea means that's
the Phoenix right the Phoenix is
something that lives ages and then
allows itself to be consumed by fire and
then re-emerges and the old phoenix gets
old and burns and the new Phoenix
re-emerges it so the real Phoenix is the
thing that's constant across those
transformations
that's the Union self that's what he
meant
the self is the element of the psyche
that remains intact across
transformations yeah yeah it's a bloody
amazing idea that's for sure and you
could think about that
that's why Jung claimed for example an
ion primarily that Christ was a symbol
of the self that was his consequence of
decades of meditation on the structure
of Christianity because it's the dying
and resurrecting part of the psyche that
remains constant across the
transformation so the ultimate order
isn't to identify with this that's your
current state of being and it isn't
identify with that because well you
can't by definition and it isn't even to
identify with that it's to let these
things go as they need to go that's a
sacrifice and to allow this continual
process of transformation to occur and
part of that is the admission that
you're wrong and so partly what you're
doing is at micro levels and at macro
levels where are you not what you could
be and when you realize that it'll take
you apart a little bit and burn you down
to your core a little bit and then allow
you to regenerate and if you do that
continually then everything that you
don't need burns away right and that's
what this means you remember in Harry
Potter you may remember that Harry goes
down so in the second volume and in the
second movie Harry's at Hogwarts so it's
the school where you learn how to be
magic because that's what you really are
and there's something that threatens the
school well part of what threatens the
school evil right Voldemort that's one
thing but at the same time it's also the
snake that lurks underneath it's the
basilisk that that threatens the school
and so the basilisk is the dragon and
when the basilisk looks at you then
you're paralyzed because you're a prey
animal and if a predator captures you in
its gaze you freeze and the reason you
freeze is because your body reacts to
the predator
as something that should turn you to
stone
sorry goes up so what do you do about
the basilisk well one thing you do is
you run and hide but the other thing you
do is go confronted in its lair and
that's what Harry Potter does now and
what's interesting about him is he's
also touched by evil right and that
means that he's an embodiment of what
you would regard as someone who's
integrated the shadow and without that
capacity he isn't able to communicate
say with snakes and that's not so good
because since there are snakes it's not
such a bad idea to know how to
communicate with them and he goes down
into the underground right into the
chaotic domain that's underneath the
school in order to find the snake and
its lair now if I remember correctly you
can you tell me if I'm wrong doesn't he
go down through a bathroom through a
toilet right well so that's an
indication of the Union dictum that
where you what you most what you need
most is to be found where you least want
to look I had a client once who actually
had a dream like that he dreamt that he
had the goal into the underground world
through an outhouse
right was very very interesting and it
was an elaboration of precisely this
theme it's what you've thrown away as of
little value to you and maybe what you
hate and hold in contempt and fear is
exactly what you have to face if you
want to go down to the place where the
transformations occur so what happens in
Harry Potter
well this Ballack's is wandering around
paralyzing everyone who isn't able to
communicate with snakes and he doesn't
fight the basilisk precisely he goes
down into its lairs the underground
world and not what what down there is
that snake has got Ginevra right his
girlfriend that's her name right it's a
it's a it's a variant of Virginia
that's a variant of virgin and the snake
always has a virgin that's one of its
characteristics right like gold he goes
down there to rescue her what happens to
him he gets bit and he's going to die so
what happens the Phoenix comes along and
cries tears into his wounds and cures
him and that's so the idea is that what
saves you in the encounter with the
snake is your capacity
to let things go and die and come back
to life right it's so interesting a that
that that story is told in that way in
that series of volumes because the plot
structure is perfect in a mythological
sense it's exactly right and the Phoenix
app actually happens to be the pet of
the main wizard which is also perfect
it's exactly right so you know what's
his name
Dumbledore yeah he's basically for all
intents and purposes God the Father and
his pet his his his close ally is the
thing that can die and that transforms
well you can see the echoes of Christian
thought in that but that isn't exactly
right it's the Christian thought and the
mythological substructure upon which the
Harry Potter volume is based are drawing
from the same underlying pool of ideas
and symbols and they're universally
accessible and you can tell that because
if they weren't that book wouldn't have
sold how many million copies how many
million copies did itself and the movies
it's unbelievably overwhelmingly
powerful she got kids to read 600 page
books like multiple volumes lining up
for them you got to ask yourself why
silly stories about magical orphans it's
like well maybe not maybe people aren't
so stupid and certainly if they happen
to be reading relatively complex books
attributing that to stupidity seems to
be rather counterproductive